Dora stay for dinner if you think you  know Dora she'll grow out of it  thank you yeah hey Dora this isn't the  jungle it's high school it's life or  death so if I don't talk to you don't  take a person oh okay we're all just  trying to survive high school is a  horrible nightmare are you I'm glad you  brought it I'm just kidding I don't  actually care we're on to something big  Dora an ancient city made of gold we're  gonna break some rules we're coming with  you Prima oh look barber on a knife on  the field trip everybody  it's a jungle puzzle  the jungle is perfectly safe  yes seriously you had that in your  backpack too  Dora and the lost city of gold  [Music]  excuse me I ain't chili con carne  we'll be G  [Music]